-Emilia, thank you so much
for coming on the show.
-Oh, my gosh.
Thank you for having me.
This is so exciting.
-I want to say "CODA" has been
nominated for almost 200 awards.
-I know. That's what
I heard the other day.
-Congratulations, by the way.
-Thank you.
-Not too shabby.
-I know. Not too bad.
-How many award shows
have you been to?
-A few, now.
-Yeah.
-I see this one over here
on most of them.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations again.
-Questlove, congratulations.
Yeah, of course.
"Summer of Soul"
out there, yeah.
-Yeah, exactly.
No, it's been really fun
kind of getting off Zoom finally
and being in a room
with all these people
that I admire.
-Yeah. Is there any people
in particular
you wanted to meet
or freaked out for?
-Yeah. Okay. So the other day,
I sat on a table
with Steven Spielberg
and I was sat there
before anyone else
had got there
and then Steven kind of
just sat almost next to me
and I was almost going
to say to him,
"I think you're
in the wrong space."
[ Laughter ]
Like how is this possible?
-"I'm not in the
Steven Spielberg section.
[ Laughter ]
He shouldn't be here."
Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
And he was just so lovely
and down-to-earth.
And then Penélope Cruz
and Javier Bardem
just sat next to me
and they're such a cool couple.
Oh, my goodness.
-Yeah. And they're fun, too.
-But it was crazy.
And I met Andrew Garfield,
who's like the loveliest guy.
[ Laughter ]
I scored some points
with my brother
because he's a big
Spider-Man fan.
So it was so much fun.
So much fun.
-I have a picture here
of you meeting someone that you
kind of freaked out for.
-[ Laughs ]
-Will Smith.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Whoo!
-How was Will?
-I love him. He's so cool.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, so I need to really stop
saying this on TV
and interviews and stuff
because I don't people
to think I fancy him, but,
[ Laughter ]
at the SAG Awards,
I kind of noticed him from afar
and I didn't want to kind of
fangirl and go up to him.
But I also just noticed how
gorgeous he was in real life.
[ Laughter ]
Like absolutely flaw--
like perfect.
Nothing was wrong with him.
-Flawless skin.
-Everything.
He was just so well-groomed
and all I could think was that
he must look and smell amazing.
[ Laughter ]
He must smell gorgeous.
-Yeah.
-And then I met him, and he did.
I was correct.
-Will Smith
does smell fantastic.
-I can confirm
he smells amazing.
-Yeah. There you go.
[ Laughter ]
If you ever wondered.
-Yeah.
-What does your family think
of all this?
How are they taking this?
You take them around with you?
-So, we went to the BAFTAs
the other day
and my grandma came with me
and she sat in the audience.
Because she hasn't come with me
for anything
because we've been in America,
so that was really, really fun.
-I met your mother backstage,
your beautiful mom.
Hi, Mom.
[ Laughter ]
But your grandmother,
God, that's amazing.
-Yeah, she's like
a glammy granny.
She's such a big personality.
[ Laughter ]
And my mum's super shy.
And so she's like, "Darling!"
And she's like walking
down the red carpet
and my mom's like,
"Where's the exit?
How do I get off the carpet?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
Your grandma sent you this,
which kind of made me laugh.
Can you explain
what this photo is?
-She's going to hate me so much.
[ Laughter ]
So these are some of the awards
that I've won
and these are my grandma's wigs.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's funny.
That is really funny.
-I mean, this is actually
not an award.
This is kitchen roll.
[ Laughter ]
Like a paper towel.
She hadn't got her mitts
on the SAG Award yet.
That's reserved.
-How funny is that.
Grandma,
keep it down-to-earth.
-Exactly.
I'm not going to get a big head
with this family.
-Absolutely not. No, no, no.
You did a great job
this weekend, by the way.
-Thank you.
-You performed
at the BAFTA Awards.
You had to sing "Both Sides,
Now," Joni Mitchell,
in front of everybody
and you crushed it.
Do you get nervous
when you're out there
and you're looking
in the audience?
You're like, "Where do I look?
What do I do?"
-Oh, yeah. I was bricking it,
if I'm being honest.
[ Laughter ]
When I was asked to sing,
I double-checked
because I just had visions
of kind of having to sing
after Jennifer Hudson singing
"Respect," or something.
And they said, "No, no,
no one's singing.
It's just you."
And I thought, you know,
what an incredible opportunity
and like when am I ever going
to be asked to sing
at the Royal Albert Hall again?
And I'm British,
so it was a big deal.
So I said yes.
Then, when the press release
was announced, it was like,
"Dame Shirley Bassey
and Emilia Jones
to sing at the BAFTAs."
I was like, "Sorry,
where did Shirley Bassey
come into it?"
[ Laughter ]
Like who invited Shirley Bassey?
And I've now got to follow her
singing "Diamonds Are Forever."
[ Laughter ]
I was so nervous.
-Like a tribute to James Bond
and you go, "That's Shirley."
-I was literally sitting
in the audience watching,
thinking,
"What have I signed up for?"
[ Laughter ]
-You're like, "No.
No one told me this at all."
-I was so nervous.
And then they got me onstage
so early, for some reason.
And so Prince William
was addressing the audience
and I was literally
just standing in front
of everyone in the darkness,
[ Laughter ]
really kind of getting more
and more nervous.
-Wow!
-So I thought, "Okay,
I'm just going to kind of focus
on a point and just, you know,
kind of relax my nerves."
And I looked up and Lady Gaga
was directly in front of me
[ Laughter ]
and I was like,
"Don't look there!
Abort! Abort! Abort!"
-Look somewhere else.
It's like, no.
So I like panned left
and it's like the whole cast
of "West Side Story."
[ Laughter ]
So I pan even further left
and it's like Alana Haim
and her sister and I was like,
"Why do I keep looking
at musicians
that do this for a living?"
[ Laughter ]
-You're like
"Where's Jimmy Fallon
at this award show?"
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy, Kenneth Branagh, anyone.
But then Alana kind of gave me
the thumbs-up
-[ Cluck ] She's cool.
-and it was fun.
-Well, I mean,
to sing "Both Sides, Now,"
it's in the movie that you sing
the beautiful song
and it's mind-blowing,
what you do with it,
because it kind of fits in
with the story, too,
you were saying,
of this daughter
kind of reaching the end of her
childhood, I guess, kind of.
And that's what Joni said
about that song,
"Both Sides, Now."
-She did.
I actually watched
a documentary,
not that long ago,
and Joni Mitchell said
"Both Sides, Now"
was the work
of her childhood's end
and in the movie, you know,
Ruby, my character,
is at the end of her childhood
and she's got to figure out
who she is outside of, yeah, her
childhood identity, basically.
-It's the perfect song.
-It is.
-It was great.
It's just beautifully done.
In fact, this is a real tweet
from the actual Joni Mitchell.
She put...
And then you replied to her
and said...
-That might has become a will.
I will become we did it.
-That will has become we did it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-So you don't have to do it now.
We framed it for you.
-Oh, my gosh.
-That's for you.
-Oh, my God. I love it.
-Can you set up
what "CODA's"
about for everyone?
You have to go see this film.
-I'm just going take this
before I forget.
[ Laughter ]
-That's yours. That is yours.
-Thank you.
So, CODA basically stands
for Child of Deaf Adults
and I play the CODA
and it basically follows Ruby,
who is a 17-year-old girl
growing up
in Gloucester, Massachusetts,
and she works
on the fishing boat
with her dad and her brother.
And then she discovers
this love for singing.
And it's going to make you
laugh and cry,
but in the best way possible,
I think.
-Your family, they need you
and they go, "Well, you're
the person in our world
that can hear."
-She basically interprets
for her family and so.
-It's just heart-wrenching
and it's beautiful
and it's funny and it's cute
and it's --
Man, you're just
so talented in it.
-Thank you.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Emilia Jones in "CODA."
Take a look at this.
-[ Sniffle ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering ]
-Emilia Jones!
"CODA" is streaming right now
on Apple TV+.